geheimes papier gelegt siedlung auf dem
mond wann wir oder warum er schon bald
mit einer sitzung auf den bund rechnen
können und wer diese errichten möchte
jetzt weit weg zum tor herzlich
willkommen
nach der sensationsmeldung das pay taxes
on nächstes jahr zwei weltraumtouristen
um den mond fliegen lassen will zieht
nun auch das konkurrenzunternehmen blue
origin nach einem nicht öffentlichen
papier zufolge steht chef besser kopf
des weltraum unternehmen orange mit der
nase in kontakt bei den gesprächen mit
der us amerikanischen luft und
raumfahrtbehörde gehe es um den plan in
drei jahren also schon in drei jahren
eine siedlung auf dem mond zu errichten
des zufolge bei wieder mal zeit für
amerika sich zum mond auszumachen und
dort angekommen dann auch weshalb zu
werden was viele von euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich für absolute utopie
halten scheint in den augen anderer
weltraum in verwerfen sehr viel mehr zu
sein
dead space unternehmen sieht das ganz
ähnlich wie give them of the time the
moon the technology with the ability and
the potential for traffic business case
zu deutsch für einen flug zum marktwert
noch zu früh zum und allerdings nicht
wir hätten mittel und zufolge die
technologien
das können und das potenzial für ein
deutsch grandiose szenario wohnräume
könnten zum beispiel aus dem hauseigenen
be mensch in wien steht für bio expertin
activity module und ist der name eines
aufblasbaren moduls das vor etwa einem
jahr mit einer falcon 9 rakete zur
internationalen raumstation iss
transportiert wurde das modul wiegt nur
rund 1360 kilogramm ist erst mal nur
rund 1,74 meter lang im aufgeblasenen
zustand dann aber 3 65 meter und hat
einen durchmesser von 32 metern
diese module könnten als wohnraum
genutzt werden zum beispiel eben auf dem
mond es wird wirklich verrückt 2018 geht
es mit basic voraussichtlich einmal um
den mund herum und zwei jahre darauf
werden wir schon dort bleiben wenn alles
so läuft wie geplant
uns bleiben nur jemand allerdings nicht
peter der die letzten zwei jahre für den
club zum kanal den schnitt der videos
und ab und an ja auch die moderation
übernommen hatte wird uns leider leider
verlassen
ich finde es wirklich schade und die
welt der podcast um ein locker humorvoll
und mit der community gestalteten feind
und entertainment pack art bereichern
wollen sie also auf keinen fall
verpassen allerdings dazu findet ihr
direkt unten in der video beschreibung
und hier viel spaß dabei und bombardiert
ihn ruhig mit dem und ansonsten wittern
zeitplan und unbedingt lauf klicken